>>> THE FDA HAS AUTHORIZED A
BOOSTER DOSE FOR PFIZER'S
COVID-19 VACCINE FOR PEOPLE 65
AND OLDER, AS WELL AS PEOPLE
WITH HIGH RISK OF SEVERE
DISEASE.
THIS IS COMING AS THE COUNTRY
SEES THE RATE OF NEW CASES
SLOWING AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
DEATHS, THOUGH, HAVE HIT OVER
2,000 A DAY.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST IN SIX
MONTHS.
AND THE PACE OF VACCINATIONS IS
THE SLOWEST THAT IT'S BEEN IN
TWO MONTHS.
FORMER FDA COMMISSIONER DR.
SCOTT GOTTLIEB IS WITH US NOW.
HIS NEW BOOK IS CALLED
"UNCONTROLLED SPREAD, WHY
COVID-19 CRUSHED US AND HOW WE
CAN DEFEAT THE NEXT PANDEMIC."
DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> THANKS A LOT.
>> SO I WANT TO ASK YOU, BECAUSE
YOU SEE THE NUMBERS, TWO NUMBERS
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
VACCINES TRENDING DOWN AFTER AN
UPTICK.
DEATHS AT 2,000 PEOPLE EVERY
DAY.
AND THERE IS A VACCINE THAT CAN
LARGELY PREVENT THOSE DEATHS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL WATCHING THAT AS
A DOCTOR?
>> WELL, LOOK, IT'S TRAGIC.
THIS IS NOW AN AVOIDABLE DEATH
CERTAINLY.
AND IF WE CAN GET MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED WE CAN START TO BRING
DOWN THE NUMBERS.
I WOULDN'T TAKE TOO MUCH SOLACE
THAT THE CASE NUMBERS ARE
DECLINING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS DRIVEN BY THE FACT THAT
CASES ARE COLLAPSING IN THE
SOUTH.
THEY HAD A DENSE WAVE OF
INFECTION.
WE ARE SEEING IT IN THE MIDWEST
IN STATES LIKE KENTUCKY, THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST WITH A DENSE
WAVE SWEEPING THROUGH THOSE
STATES.
OHIO.
THERE IS A PERCEPTION THAT
HIGHER VACCINATION RATES IN THE
NORTHEAST AND I'M HERE IN THE
NORTHEAST TODAY AND WE HAVE
IMMUNITY FROM PRIOR INFECTION
IMPERVIOUS TO A DELTA WAVE IN
THIS PART OF THE COUNTRY, I
DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
THE CASE.
I THINK WE WILL SEE INFECTIONS
PICK UP AS KIDS GO BACK TO
SCHOOLS AND THE WEATHER GETS
COLD AND PEOPLE START TO GO BACK
TO WORK.
>> I KNOW YOU TALK TO EXPERTS
AROUND THE WORLD.
ARE YOU TALKING TO A DOCTOR IN
NEW ZEALAND OR ENGLAND WHERE THE
VACCINATION RATES ARE SO HIGH
AND LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE U.S. AND THEY THINK IT'S
NUTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> YEAH, LOOK, WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY IN THIS COUNTRY
GETTING PEOPLE VACCINATED.
THE OVERALL RATE OF VACCINATION
RATES OF ADULTS OVER AGE OF 18
IS ABOUT 77%, WHICH IS PRETTY
GOOD.
WE HAVE BEEN BUILDING THAT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST SIX,
SEVEN MONTHS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN PUSHING OUT THE VACCINE,
DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB GETTING
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO GET TO 80% TO 85% TO
HAVE ENOUGH VACCINATION IN THE
POPULATION THAT YOU START TO SEE
CASE RATES DECLINE AND THE
VELOCITY OF SPREAD START TO
SLOW.
WE HAVE IMMUNITY IN THE
POPULATION FROM PRIOR INFECTION.
THAT DOES COUNT.
PEOPLE PREVIOUSLY INFECTED DO
HAVE SOME IMMUNITY FROM
CONTINUED INFECTION.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT WILL
LAST.
PEOPLE WHO ARE RELYING ON
NATURAL IMMUNITY THEY, TOO, WILL
NEED TO GET VACCINATED AT SOME
POINT.
>> WHAT DOES WINTER LOOK LIKE
HERE IN THE U.S.?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THIS DELTA WAVE MAY BE
THE LAST WAVE OF INFECTION.
ASSUMING NOTHING UNEXPECTED
HAPPENS.
WE DON'T GET A VARIANT THAT
PIERCES THE IMMUNITY BY
VACCINATION.
SO ASSUMING THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN,
AND I THINK IT'S UNLIKELY, THIS
WILL BE THE LAST MAJOR WAVE.
THIS BECOMES A MORE SYSTEMIC
ENDEMIC RISK.
YOU HAVE SPREAD BUT NOT AT THE
SAME RATE AS IT IS RIGHT NOW.
IT SETTLES INTO MORE OF A
SEASONAL PATTERN AND BECOMES A
SEASONAL FLU, SOMETHING ON PAR
WITH THE FLU.
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE WITH FLU, AND IF WE HAVE
COVID CIRCULATING, THE
CUMULATIVE DEATH AND DISEASE IS
GOING TO BE TOO MUCH FOR SOCIETY
TO BEAR.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN THE WINTERTIME TO
CUT DOWN ON THE RISK OF THINGS
LIKE WORK AND SCHOOLS, IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY IN INDOOR SPACES,
AIR INFILTRATION, PUTTING IN
PLACE HAND WASHING STATIONS,
ENCOURAING HAND WASHING
STATIONS, WEARING MASKS
VOLUNTARILY IN PUBLIC SPACES
DURING PEAK COVID AND FLU
SEASON.
YOU WILL SEE MASKS BECOMING MORE
CULTURALLY ACCEPTABLE IN PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY.
ONCE WE GET PAST THIS COVID
EPIDEMIC, IT BECOMES A MORE
ENDEMIC RISK.
>> YOU SAID YESTERDAY WE'RE
HEADING IN A DIRECTION WHERE
MASKS WILL BECOME OPTIONAL.
CAN YOU BE CLEAR ON THAT ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE NOW ON MASKS
INDOORS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT SCHOOLS, FOR
INSTANCE.
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE ARE HEADING
TO A PLACE WHERE MASKS ARE
OPTIONAL?
>> YEAH, LOOK.
WE NEED TO BASE THIS ON
PREVALENCE.
ONCE THE PREVALENCE STARTS TO
DECLINE, A LOT OF THE STEPS WE
HAVE BEEN TAKING BECOME MORE
ROUTINE AND FADE INTO THE
BACKGROUND, BECOME MORE
OPTIONAL.
PEOPLE WEAR MASKS WHEN
PREVALENCE IS HIGH AND TAKE THEM
OFF WHEN PREVALENCE DECLINES.
RIGHT NOW PREVALENCE IS STILL
VERY HIGH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SOUTH DURING
THE PEAK OF THEIR EPIDEMIC THIS
SUMMER, STATES LIKE FLORIDA,
MISSISSIPPI, ALABAMA HAD 110
CASES PER 100,000 PEOPLE PER
DAY.
NEW CASES DIAGNOSED.
THAT IS EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH.
NEW YORK CITY IN THE SUMMERTIME,
WHEN THEY HAD THEIR MINI DELTA
WAVE, THEY HAD 20 CASES PER
100,000 PER DAY.
THAT IS THE LEVEL WE WILL SEE ON
THE BACK END OF THIS WAVE.
I DON'T THINK WE WILL GET DOWN
TO LEVELS WHERE IT'S TWO TO FOUR
CASES PER DAY WHICH IS WHAT WE
HAD IN JUNE AND JULY.
I THINK WE'RE STILL GOING TO
HAVE A LOT OF CASES THIS WINTER
JUST BECAUSE IT'S THE
WINTERTIME.
THIS IS A WINTER PATHOGEN.
IT LIKES TO SPREAD IN THE COLD
WEATHER.
WHEN IT GOES DOWN, YOU WILL LIFT
SOME OF THE MANDATES AND MASKS
WILL BE OPTIONAL.
PEOPLE WILL WEAR THEM IF THEY
ARE AT RISK.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU WILL BE
MANDATING THE USE OF MASKS.
BUT WE'RE A LONG WAY FROM THAT.
WE HAVE TO GET THROUGH ANOTHER
SURGE OF INFECTION AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THIS ISN'T OVER.
JUST BECAUSE THE SOUTH IS COMING
DOWN AND THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
LOOKS LIKE IT IS FALLING, THIS
HAS BEEN HIGHLY REGIONALIZED
EPIDEMIC AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SO.
>> WHEN DO YOU THINK MASKS WILL
BE OPTIONAL IN SCHOOLS?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET TO A POINT WHERE THE
VACCINES ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE IN
SCHOOLS.
THEY AREN'T INHERENTLY SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS.
MASKS ARE ONE TOOL.
TESTING.
IMPLEMENT TWICE A WEEK
ASYMPTOMATIC TESTING OF STUDENTS
YOU CAN CUT DOWN THE RISK
DRAMATICALLY.
AND KEEPING THEM IN DEFINED
SOCIAL PODS.
NOT LETTING STUDENTS ENTER
MINGLE BUT KEEPING THEM IN THEIR
CLASS AND HAVING THEM MOVE
AROUND THE SCHOOL HOUSE WITHIN
THEIR CLASS.
YOU WANT TO PREVENT OUTBREAKS IN
THOSE SETTINGS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT COVID HASN'T BEEN
DEADLY IN CHILDREN, AND
THANKFULLY IT THATS NOT.
THIS WOULD BE A WHOLE DIFFERENT
BALL GAME.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE LONG-TERM
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS VIRUS.
YOU DON'T WERE WANT TO SEE IT
BECOME EPIDEMIC IN CHILDREN.
THERE ARE STATES IN THE SOUTH
WHERE THIS RIPPED THROUGH SCHOOL
HOUSES.
THAT IS DEEPLY UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LONG-TERMISM INDICATIONS OF
COVID.
>> YOU SIT ON THE PFIZER BOARD.
WE HAVE SEEN THE RECOMMENDATION
FOR OLDER AMERICANS AND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE VULNERABLE.
OF COURSE THIS IS STILL GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS THIS WEEK
WITH THE CDC.
THE WHITE HOUSE GOT AHEAD OF
THIS PROCESS TALKING ABOUT A
ROLLOUT FOR ALL AMERICANS OF A
BOOSTER SHOT.
DO YOU THINK THEY JUMPED THE
GUN?
DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT
JUMPED THE GUN?
>> NO, I DON'T.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO TALK ABOUT A
SPECIFIC DATE.
THAT CREATED THE PERCEPTION THEY
WERE GETTING IN FRONT OF THE
REGULATORY PROCESS.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE BOOSTERS
AVAILABLE TO AN OLDER POPULATION
PARTICULARLY IN NURSING HOMES,
IT TAKES WEEKS TO GET THAT IN
PLACE, TO GET THE LOGISTICS IN
PLACE TO DEPLOY THE BOOSTERS.
IF THEY WANT TO START
ADMINISTERING THIS MONTH OR
EARLY NEXT WEEK, THEY NEED TO
HAVE ANAPROX MAT DATE.
IT TOOK FOUR WEEKS TO VACCINATE
1.34 RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOMES.
THIS WAS OVER A TIME PERIOD WHEN
WE WERE LOSING 7,000 PEOPLE A
WEEK IN NURSING HOMES.
WE HAD TO WAIT FOUR WEEKS TO GET
INTO THE NURSING HOMES TO START
VACCINATING BECAUSE THEY HADN'T
PLANNED INTO ADVANCE TO GO INTO
THE FACILITIES.
IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET
CONSENTS WITH THE PATIENTS.
YOU HAD TO GET THE CONCEPT BY
THE FAMILIES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T
WANT TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE.
THEY WANTED LOGISTICS IN PLACE.
I